so we've got this function f of X that
is piecewise continuous is defined over
several intervals here for X being or
for 0 less than X being less than or
equal to 2 f of X is natural log of X
for any X is larger than 2 well then f
of X is going to be x squared times the
natural log of X and what we want to do
is we want to find the limit of f of X
as X approaches 2 and what's interesting
about the value two is that that's at
the that's the essentially the boundary
between these two intervals if we wanted
to evaluate it at two we would fall into
this first interval F of 2 well 2 is
less than or equal to 2 it's and it's
greater than 0
so f of 2 f of 2 would be pretty
straight forward that would just be
natural log of 2 but that's not
necessarily what the limit is going to
be before defiant figure out what the
limit is going to be we should think
about well what's the limit as we
approach from the left what's the limit
as we approach from the right and do
those exist and if they do exist are
they the same thing and if they are the
same thing well then we have a well
defined limit so let's let's do that
let's first think about the limit the
limit of f of X as we approach 2 from
the left from values lower than 2 well
this is going to be the case where we're
going to be operating in this interval
right over here we're operating from
values less than 2 and we're going to be
approaching 2 from the left and so will
fall under this clause and so since this
this clause or case is continuous over
the interval in which we're operating
and for sure' between or for all values
greater than 0 and less than or equal to
2 this limit is going to be equal to
just this clause evaluated it to because
it's continuous over the interval so
this is just going to be the natural log
of 2 all right so now let's think about
the limit from the right hand side from
values greater than 2 so the limit the
limit of f of X as X approaches 2 from
the right hand side
well even though two falls into this
clause as soon as we go anything greater
than two we fall in this clause so we're
going to be approaching two essentially
using this case and once again this case
here is is is continuous for all X
values not only greater than to actually
you know greater than or equal to two
and so for for this one over here we can
make the same argument that this limit
is going to be this clause evaluated at
two because once again if we were just
evaluated the function at two it falls
into this clause but if we're
approaching from the right well if we're
approaching from the right those are X
values greater than 2 so this Clause is
what's at play so we'll evaluate this
clause at 2 so because it is continuous
so this is going to be 2 squared times
the natural log of 2 and so this is
equal to 4 times the natural log of 2 4
times the natural log of 2 so the
right-hand limit does exist the
left-hand limit does exist but the thing
that might jump out at you is that these
are two different values we approach a
different value from the left as we do
from the right if you were to graph this
you would see a jump in the actual graph
you would see a discontinuity occurring
there and so for this one in particular
you have that that jump discontinuity
this limit would not exist because the
left handed limit and the right hand
limit go to two different values so
limit so this does not exist